foreign
is in Nashville hey Sarah welcome to the
Ramsay show
thank you for having
me sure how are you better than I
deserve how can we help today
I'm kind of in a financial crisis and
I'm not really sure what to do
um my house is in the process of being
foreclosed on oh my and I don't know if
I should
just throw in the towel or fight so my
husband
I lost my husband four years ago and
we've been surviving off the Social
Security and insurance payments
and um the insurance company filed an
appeal and froze the payments
the beginning of the year and it just
through my finances in a
Whirlwind and I went back to work
how old was your husband
he was 36. what happened
he was working for a roofing company in
Hendersonville
and he fell through a skylight working
on a roof 30 feet
oh my I'm so sorry and um
he suffered a cerebral hemorrhage and
the insurance company that was what
workers comp or liability insurance for
the for the employer
says they're not liable
yeah they filed an appeal
and you have an attorney
I have one through um workman's comp and
they have denied the appeal and
restarted my payments
but that put me in a place where I got
behind really behind and then by the
time I got a job I was I was drowning
yeah so do they have they set a date on
your foreclosure
[Music]
so we get a little time a little action
here we've got 45 days to work on this
that's good news what is your home worth
3.75. and what do you owe on it
64. okay you are not getting foreclosed
on
breathe
I know how to stop I mean I know this is
my fault it's okay it's not your fault
nope it's not your fault life has
happened to you you've had a tragedy
honey
so to start with I Want You to Breathe
this in
100 I've been doing this for 30 years
you are not getting foreclosed on
okay we're not going to allow you to
lose that much equity
we have our ways okay we're not gonna do
this okay so you're you're good you're
okay now do we have some problems that
we need to address yes
okay we do but you're not going to lose
this house
I'm a hundred percent sure of it okay Do
You Believe Me Do You Believe Me
I do okay it's my job to do this it's
all I know how to do and I'm the best in
the world at it okay you're not gonna
lose this house now so you've been
living for three or four years off of
insurance payments you were not working
before he passed is that right no that's
correct so how old are you
I'm 40. and what is your new job
I am a I work for um Lowe's corporate
office it's a remote position okay and
what do you make
uh
twenty dollars an hour okay good good
and you're getting 40 or more hours
yes correct okay so can you do a budget
and eat on that
and pay your house payment if you were
current
okay all right how much is your house
payment
600 okay and how many house payments
behind are you
um five
five okay so you need three thousand
dollars to get current plus some fees
right
right okay that's correct okay all right
do you own anything
two cars you still got his own car
no my car got repoed last month
okay all right how are you uh you have a
car at all
no okay all right
and so you don't have anybody around you
and family and things do you
I lost my father six months before I
lost my husband okay
how many how many kids you got
four okay how old are they
[Music]
um 2017 eight and six
six
okay
all right
um are you involved in a church locally
so here's what we're gonna do okay we're
gonna wrap our arms around you and make
sure you're okay and we're gonna put a
bunch of people in your life and um
you're gonna follow the instructions of
these people and we're gonna save your
house and we're gonna get you back up on
your feet and get you a car and get you
going again okay
all right we've got we've got Ramsay
counselors right here in your town we're
we're in your town and we'll use one of
our on staff people to take care of you
okay her name is Lisa and Austin's going
to hook you up with her and she's going
to get in touch with the mortgage
company and um this is taken care of
we're going to take care of it okay and
we're also going to get you connected to
a local church and get you some help and
get some people around you because you
need some Community loving you well
you've been doing all this by yourself
and it's terrifying
yeah
you're gonna be okay
I just want to do it the right way and
teach my kids the right way yeah
well honey it's hard what's your I don't
know if there's a right way to lose your
husband when he's 36.
I don't think there's a right way to do
that it just hurts and it's messy
and then everything gets discombobulated
can I tell you one of the greatest gifts
you can give your kid right now
all four of them
you can let them know that they're not
crazy and that you miss their dad too
oh I do every day when they get to see
mom cry and they get to see Mom go get a
job and they get to see Mom do the
unthinkable which is reach out for help
which is something that Sarah does not
like to do
when they get to see that they get to
see what it looks like when a grown-up
gets hit with everything
and they get to see a community rally
around and they begin to regain their
faith in humanity the light comes back
on a little bit and they get to see that
by watching their mom go through it
and so you you feel like you're failing
them you feel like you're failing
everybody it's all coming down on you
I want you to know you're changing your
family tree because they're getting to
see a strong mom say enough I can't do
any more we can somebody help me they
get to see that in real time and you're
gonna have to follow these steps the
hard work is just beginning right but
they're gonna get to watch their mom
reach out they're gonna watch their mom
walk back in the doors of a church and
say I can't do this by myself anymore
they're going to watch their mom
um say hey kids I gotta go to work
they're gonna get to watch their mom do
all that
and they're going to take those lessons
into their families
okay I just want to make them proud yeah
oh you are trust me you are the fact
that you're standing and breathing
you're making them proud on top of what
Dave just said I'm gonna throw in our
friends at better help I'm gonna throw
in three months or six months of free
counseling for you okay
thank you and hang on the line here at
uh Austin will get you connected with
our friends at better help and they have
been great great partners with me and
the Ramsey Show here and they're gonna
take care of you for the next six months
okay
you can do that from your phone you can
do it from your computer we got you what
kind of mortgage is this FHA VA or
conventional
I think it's uh I know it's an arm
but I think it's a conventional
because who has the mortgage who's the
mortgage company
Americus
oh okay good good good good good okay
that's wonderful you're just giving me a
hard time about everything because I'm
not on the mortgage but I'm authorized
on it yeah they don't have they don't
have they don't have any choices here
okay there are laws and regulations and
things that are they think they're in
control of this they're not Sarah I wish
you could watch this Dave just gave the
smile when Dave gives the smile crap's
about to get done
hang on uh I was gonna pick up we'll get
you taken care of kiddo